je vous demande l accueillir malik
bentalha et franck gastambide roumanie
[Applaudissements]
car
le
j'ai une petite surprise pour parce que
je vous ai offert des chaussures voilà
je vous ai offerts de basket fait
longtemps que je devais lui offrait des
baskets et j'ai une autre mais pourquoi
non mais c'est bon on va pas dire
pourquoi on sait pas pourquoi
une raison à ça ce cadeau et c'est bon
voilà c'est votre cadeau voilà je vous
ai racheté les baskets voilà abîmer les
autres alors voilà c'est parce que il
fait pas de cadeau pour rien le mec vous
le savez tous ce truc là c'est un beau
cadeau assez de la jordan c'est une très
belle paire merci beaucoup mais c'est
pour se faire pardonner d'une d'une
usine est d'une bêtise d'une on va c'est
bon je dois parler deux secondes ce qui
est hélas toujours et pas réveiller
détient aux médias ouais ouais là on a
des comédiens autour de la table sur sa
passe un pic d'audience à chaque escale
est à poil km/h à qui s'y prend mais
j'ai un truc à te confier je dois dire
d'abord que c'est francky ma force et
non je m'appelle pas natalité de sissi
duparc c'est à dire l'acte us qui dit
toujours oui et si depuis tout à l'heure
y en a marre qui me dit tu vas dire
bonjour à natacha pas dire bonjour à la
tâche a dit s'il s'appelle natasha poly
dire bonjour
alors je vous raconte tout oui alors une
surprise passée où met on recompte
contre 25 la chaussure nombre à oui on
raconte alors parce qu'il ya des fois il
ya des choses qui vous sont arrivés à
vous dans l'équipe et les des gens
disent c'est vrai qu'il fait s'annonce
comme très grave s'il fait ça mais en
fait il fait ça quand il t'aime beaucoup
et alors cet été je trouvais plus mes
baskets et je vois lui et bentalha qui
se marre qu'ils se marchent ne crois pas
j'y vais doucement ce que je me dis me
prépare un coup et quand j'arrive je
retrouve mes baskets dans lequel cyril a
fait ses besoins
et anciens et c'est à cette période que
tu rencontres une personne qui va
beaucoup compter pour toi franck qui va
énormément aidé pour tes réalisations tu
va le former sur plein de disciplines
à cette époque il ya ton documentaire
good dot c'est ça est ce que je me
trompe pour l'instant non non tout est
vrai et bien cet ami devenu très très
proches au fil du temps va également td
surgénération molosses est ce que tu
vois de qui je veux parler génération
molosses ces noms du boys band
regardez voila voila c'est une trappe à
deux générations boli venons en aux
faits avec tous ces indices est ce que
tu penses à une personne en particulier
si je te dis ludovic est ce que ça
t'évoque quelque chose c'est possible tu
partagé beaucoup de choses avec lui il
est mort de rire
regarde
ludovic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une fois qu'il réponde à dire
réponse je suis plus en une minute
d'accord attention plus ça va plus ça va
aller vite
attention à ce que vous êtes prêts les
gars
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à
[ __ ] c'est tout dit tenir
alors avec moins d'eau que j'avais pas
vu non je te suis faso sa caisse non je
ne suis pas c
beaucoup d'appels on avait une photo de
vacances de vous aimer arrêté sans
déconner non mais tu connais ludovic non
bien sûr que non ludovic si et quand par
exemple en 2003 quand j'ai quand j'étais
avec toi sur le sur l'ordre voulait
dormir à la maison à la rue de la
roquette sûrement clic-clac non non tout
est faux pour parents travaux est ce que
vous connaissez cette personne n'a bien
sûr que l'on quoi vous ne venez pas nous
dire que l'ong et ses annexes c'est quoi
oui
non mais ça fait un appel non mais sans
déconner franck vraiment aucun rapport
non vraiment non alors il est venu me
dire pendant la pub montre à nos galères
le bon mec épreuve à me remettre
[Rires]
waouh
[Applaudissements]